.
>>> TODAY MORE GRIM NEWS.
NEARLY 300,000 NEW INFECTIONS
AND SOME 2,000 DEATHS REPORTED
MAKING IT INDIA'S HIGHEST RISE
IN INFECTIONS AND DEATHS IN A
SINGLE DAY.
THINGS ARE SO BAD IN SOME PLACES
THAT HOSPITALS ARE RUNNING LOW
ON BEDS AND ON OXYGEN.
EARLIER A LOCAL OFFICIAL IN
WESTERN INDIA SAID 22 COVID
PATIENTS ON VENTILATORS SUPPORT
DIED WHILE WAITING FOR OXYGEN
SUPPORT THAT WAS DAMAGED IN AN
ACCIDENT.
WHAT IS GOING ON?
>> FIRST, THANK YOU FOR HAVING
ME.
WE'RE GOING THROUGH PRETTY MUCH
THE WORST POSSIBLE PHASE OF THE
PANDEMIC HERE.
THE HEALTH SYSTEM IS NOT ABLE TO
KEEP PACE WITH THE SHEER NUMBER
OF CASES COMING IN.
IT'S EXACTLY THAT EXAMPLE OF
WHERE THE HEALTH SYSTEM IS
GETTING OVERWHELMED WITH
PATIENTS.
PATIENTS ARE HAVING TO SHARE
BEDS.
THEY ARE HAVING TO WAIT FOR
HOURS FOR ADMISSIONS AND
HOSPITALS AND IT IS TRULY A
TRAGIC CRISIS RIGHT NOW.
>> LET'S DRILL DOWN ON THIS A
BIT.
IS THE INDIAN VARIANT TO BLAME
HERE?
>> POSSIBLY, BUT WE DON'T KNOW.
WE DON'T HAVE THE DATA THAT CAN
CONFIRM THAT.
THE NUMBER OF NEW CASES DROPPED
DRAMATICALLY AND I THINK WHAT
THAT DID WAS TO INSTILL A SENSE
OF FALSE SECURITY IN EVERYBODY
THAT WE PAST -- THE WORST WAS
BEHIND US.
A LOT OF THE BEHAVIORS THAT HAD
BEEN IN PLAY MOSTLY WENT DOWN.
PEOPLE WERE OUT AND ABOUT MUCH
MORE.
MASK WEARING DECLINED
SIGNIFICANTLY.
A WILL THE OF LARGE ACTIVITIES,
LARGE GATHERINGS WERE SCHEDULED.
THE COUNTRY BEHAVED AS IF THE
WORST WAS OVER.
WE MANY THE TASK FORCE HAD A
SERI
SER
SERIES OF MEETINGS IN JANUARY
AND FEBRUARY.
THERE WAS A WILL THE OF
NERVOUSNESS THIS COULD BE A DIP
BUT NOT THE END OF THE PANDEMIC.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED.
>> THIS WAS AVOIDABLE, IS THAT
WHAT YOU'RE TELLING ME IN?
>> I THINK IT WAS AVOIDABLE IF
WE KEPT OUR GUARD AND BEEN MORE
CAREFUL ADD A COUNTRY, AS A
PEOPLE, THESE NUMBERS WOULD HAVE
BEEN MUCH LESS.
WHAT WE DON'T KNOW IS THE AFFECT
OF THE VARIANTS.
IT COULD BE WITH THE SAME
BEHAVIORS, WE WOULD HAVE HAD A
SURGE.
IT'S TRUE IF MASK WEARING, IF
DISTANCING, IF ALL OF THESE
PRACTICES HAD BEEN FOLLOWED,
PROBABLY WE WOULD SEE A
DIFFERENT SET OF NUMBERS.
>> NEW DEHLI JUST ENTERED A WEEK
LONG LOCKDOWN THAT COULD EXTEND
FOR LONGER.
YOU SAID THERE WAS A LOT OF
NERVOUSNESS.
YOU UNDERSTAND PEOPLE DROP THEIR
GUARD.
THIS COULD HAVE BEEN AVOIDABLE.
ARE THE SORT OF RESTRICTIONS
THAT ARE GOING INTO PLACE NOW
ENOUGH, DO YOU BELIEVE?
>> THERE ARE ESSENTIAL AT THIS
POINT.
ONE OF THE CHALLENGES OF NOT
BEING CAREFUL EARLY ON IS THERE
ARE FEWER AND FEWER OPTIONS LEFT
IN TERMS OF WHAT TO DO TO BREAK
THE CHAIN OF TRANSMISSION.
IN OUR REPORT, WE HAVE BASICALLY
RECOMMENDED THREE DIFFERENT SETS
OF OPTIONS AND THE FIRST IS HOW
DO YOU BREAK THE CHAIN OF
TRANSMISSION AND ONE OF THOSE
MECHANISMS IS RESTRICTING
ACTIVITY.
IT'S A DANGEROUS POLICY OPTION
BECAUSE KNOCKDOWNS THAT ARE
SEVERE AND LONG LASTING HURT THE
ECONOMY.
THEY HURT THE POOR.
OUR RECOMMENDATION VERY MUCH WAS
TO LIMIT AND LOCALIZE THESE LOCK
D
LOCKDOWNS BASED ON THE SURGES IN
THE AREA.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT YOU'RE
SEEING UNFOLDING.
THIS IS BEING DONE WITH A GREAT
AMOUNT OF RELUCTANCE.
I DON'T THINK THERE'S ANY
POLITICAL LEADER IN THE COUNTRY
THAT WANTS TO IMPOSE LOCKDOWNS
BUT AT THIS STAGE THE STEP HAD
TO BE TAKEN TO REDUCE THE NUMBER
OF NEW CASES.
THE OTHER THING THAT HAS TO
HAPPEN IS MUCH, MUCH GREATER
EMPHASIS ON MASK WEARING AND A
COMPLETE BAN ON LARGE EVENTS AND
LARGE GATHERINGS.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT KICKING
IN NOW.
IT WASN'T IN PLACE FOR THE LAST
MONTH.
WE REALLY SEEN THE AFFECTS OF
THAT PLAY OUT.
OUR SECOND SET OF
RECOMMENDATIONS WAS REALLY
AROUND STRENGTHENING THE HEALTH
SYSTEM AND UNFORTUNATELY THIS IS
NOT SOMETHING THAT CAN BE DONE
OVERNIGHT.
AGAIN, WITH THE SURGE, WE HAVE
TO SEE THE EDGES AND THE LIMIT
TS OF THE HEALTH SYSTEM IN TERMS
OF THE AVAILABILITY OF DOCTORS
AND NURSES AND MEDICAL STAFF,
AMBULANCE SERVICES, AMBULANCE
DRIVERS.
EVERYTHING IS IN SHORT SUPPLY.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT HAD TO BE
RESOLVED ON AN EMERGENCY BASIS
BUT IT WILL TAKE A FEW WEEKS.
NONE OF THESE ISSUES AROUND THE
LACK OF OXYGEN, THE LACK OF
MEDICINES, NONE OF THAT IS
RESOLVABLE OVERNIGHT ONCE
NUMBERS HIT THESE LEVELS.
>> IS THE HEALTH CARE SYSTEM
COLLAPSING AT THIS POINT?
>> IT'S UNDER SEVERE STRAIN IN
SEVERAL PART OF THE COUNTRY.
THIS WOULD BE, INDIA'S HEALTH
SYSTEM IS NOTORIOUSLY UNDER
FUNDED.
WE KNOW THAT.
WE HAVE THE PUBLIC SPENDING ON
HEALTH IS AROUND 1.5% OF GDP.
THESE ARE LOW NUMBERS BY ANY
STANDARDS.
IN A SENSE WHAT THE PANDEMIC IS
DOING IS SHOWING A SPOTLIGHT ON
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN THERE'S
CHRONIC LONG TERM UNDER
INVESTMENT HEALTH SECTOR.
YES, IT'S UNDER ENORMOUS STRAIN.
IF THE NUMBERS GO DOWN OVER THE
NEXT FEW DAYS THEN WE WILL GET A
BIT OF A RESPITE BUT THAT
REMAINS TO BE SEEN.
>> WHAT CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT
THIS NEW, SO-CALLED INDIAN
VARIANT AND HOW CONCERNING IS
IT?
>> AS I SAID, IT'S A LITTLE HARD
TO KNOW RIGHT NOW WHAT THE EXACT
EFFECT OF THIS MUTANT VARIANT
WILL BE.
WE'RE BEGINNING TO START
MEASURING WHERE IT'S SHOWING UP
AND HOW IT'S SHOWING UP BUT IT'S
TOO EARLY TO REALLY SAY WHETHER
THIS IS DRIVING INFECTIONS.
WHAT WE DO KNOW FROM THE DATA
THAT IS COMING IN IS THAT THIS
TIME THERE IS A LOT MORE
INFECTIONS WITHIN HOUSEHOLDS.
IT DEFINITELY -- THERE SEEMS TO
BE GREATER LEVEL OF
INFECTIOUSNESS.
EVEN IF ONE PERSON IN A
HOUSEHOLD IS INFECTED, VERY
QUICKLY THE FAMILY IS GETTING
INFECTED WHICH WASN'T THE CASE
IN FIRST WAVE.
THERE DOES SEEM TO BE SOME
DIFFERENCE HERE.
IT'S TOO SOON TO TELL.
WE HAVE NOT DONE ENOUGH
SEQUENCING TO TRACK THE VARIANT
AND PREDICT THE EXTENT TO WHICH
IT IS AFFECTING TRANSMISSION
RATES RIGHT NOW.
>> YOU TALKED EARLIER ABOUT
IMPORTANCE OF RESTRICTING PUBLIC
GATHERINGS.
PRIME MINISTER MODI'S RULING
POLITICAL PARTY HAS SAID IT
WOULD HOLD QUOTE, SMALL PUBLIC
GATHERINGS WITH A CAP OF 500
PEOPLE.
THIS IS ELECTION SEASON, OF
COURSE.
THAT DOESN'T SOUND LIKE A SMALL
NUMBER TO ME.
THAT IS AFTER TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE WERE SEEN AT RALLIES
ORGANIZED BY MODI'S PARTY.
ISN'T THIS RECKLESS GIVEN WHAT
IS GOING ON AT THE MOMENT?
>> I SUSPECT THE NUMBERS WILL
DROP.
THE 500 NUMBER SEEMS LARGE.
IT'S A MUCH SMALLER PROPORTION
OF THE TENS AND THOUSANDS WE
WERE SEEING EARLIER.
NOW THERE'S A SENSE OF CRISIS
WHICH IS FAIRLY WIDESPREAD
AMONGST THE GENERAL POP YOU LAG
AS WELL AS AMONG THE POLITICAL
LEADERSHIP